so we talked about this a little bit L
in Angelina at CinemaCon kind of the
evolution of your relationship and I was
thinking you were 14 when you do the
first valve you're 21 now we just deep
dive a little bit more into the
evolution of the relationship between
you all because I mean I felt the love
when you were both talking about each
other and you especially we're talking
about how you love how your your
relationship has evolved on and off
screen definitely yes I mean I think
when the first Maleficent felt like such
a huge part of my life and I've never
I'd never had done a movie of that scale
before you know at that age and so it
just the whole experience was just you
know stamped in my life and when I heard
we were gonna you know go off to do a
second one obviously all of our lives
you know have changed and grown up a lot
and so much like the characters
Maleficent and Aurora our relationship
has gotten a lot closer to because we
really know each other a lot now and
definitely the process of filming the
second movie we cuz also I'm older so we
can talk about different things you know
I was you know blow your mind through
now like she can have a cocktail with
you a glass of wine but you are always
very you always held yourself fair you
always impressed
oh you're such a brown longer self so so
well she always had such grace and it
always such a strong actor that you
never seemed like a child so you were
and you've also maintained which I think
is almost unheard of in this business
such sweetness and gratitude for for the
job and for every minute and for
everybody and and you know just hasn't
in any way been and I know like you've
had your ups and downs you know it's
like everybody and you go through things
but you've just maintained this this
loveliness and thing that always strikes
me about who is this inherent joy you
just have this inherent joy it's in your
shoulder almost confused by it in either
side good what is it what where does
that come from it's a sleeping people I
know yeah naturally it really is a
spooky bet should have been the movie
but you ever think yeah we all need to
tap into that because it does radiate
definitely don't you have done an
admirable job going against her own
nature to raise this child but now she
will finally get the love of a real
mother
tonight I consider Elora
my Oh Michelle of course we're excited
to see you in this film and now that
I've seen it
Oh y'all just wait til you see the two
of you I love it I listened to the GUP
podcast that you're on with Gwyneth
Paltrow before before I saw the film and
it struck me that you said you're always
fearful that you're gonna get fired from
a job during your first week always were
you ever fired no we're not that come
from I want it to be fired of people
that's always try to get myself fired
right before a shoot I'm gonna have to
find out where you wanted to get fired
that's a great question where does that
come from I don't know I think it comes
from not having a background of formal
training you know in the beginning and I
think when I started out a lot of actors
were coming out of Juilliard and you
know and I I was just this young person
from Orange County and kind of just
getting by on my instincts purely and I
think for the longest time I felt like
that wasn't really enough and maybe
didn't give me the credibility and and
maybe because I I had to find my my
technique as I went along that you know
it didn't I didn't sort of start from a
real secure place listen if the career
you've had is you getting by on your
instincts may we all try to tap into
that instinct but you just learned to
trust them more and more as you you know
as you do it more and you get older
hopefully I had a blast on this though
so you're gonna feel like you're fired
I'm pretty confident with the villains
now
yeah I kind of know where to go for that
yeah when I asked about the ping pong
because we love that behind-the-scenes
song they set him up for the trailers
okay not trying to cause a weight here
who won the beating like I could have
played in that outfit these like flowy
little light things and I'm an armor and
I'm up to here who won the ping-pong
tournament oh you did I'm pretty good at
ping pong yes yes that joy just comes
like we went paintballing tushy you were
better at that
joy yeah and you see like a grand
depression yeah even though I shot your
security guard in the Magnum I guess it
was and there right there was paintball
apparently anything else you'd like to
tell Michelle I'm sure lots of things
yeah we will definitely take you
paintball thank you tapping into a theme
for the movie of course is Maleficent
not wanting her grown daughter to kind
of find her way go off and make her own
choice and just be who she's destined or
really wanted to be talking to the
mama's in the room have you guys had
that problem or are you now having that
problem like letting the kiddos go or
seeing them grow or just letting them
fly it's a it's a push and pull because
I do think it's a part you feel like
you're losing literally a part of your
body but
you know I'm I mean at the same time you
what you really want for your children
is for them to be incredibly independent
and to to and so you you've succeeded in
doing what you set out to do so you're
incredibly proud but it's hard to make
that separate it was for me with it was
challenging for you Angley because yours
are all in different stages because
there's still you know yeah they still
like the little I just I feel like my
world expands is their world expands
yeah and learn so much from them and
yeah I love this stage I'm feeling I do
too I do too I'm excited but but maybe
it's all so different it's gonna be
different for different kids yeah this
this Maddox was so ready and he was yeah
choices are so good I love how smart
they are and how funny they are and
their sense of humor comes out and it's
really it's it is it's fun I'm Li want
to talk about the the interview that you
did with Tattler for a second because
you were talking about how there's you
know this stigma of women in the
workplace especially in Hollywood that
women aren't supposed to get along
they're not supposed to you know support
each other and you know that that's
ridiculous oh I was gonna say number one
how did you get so wise so soon and
number two were these ladies do they
help aid in letting you know what it's
like to support women yeah I just feel
like since you know from a young age
obviously my sister is in the business
and all like always interviews would
always be about asking me oh well aren't
you guys must be really jealous of each
other and like so like interviewers are
it's always like they want to pit yeah
it's like they want to pit women against
each other and so there's that stigma of
like oh well if you guys work together
you there's just this jealousy on
Saturdays and it's just so not true
because it's the people you're like
you're trying to put words in my mouth
so
yeah because I've only had great
relationships with actresses and from I
remember you even see you especially
said that about this film of how you
really felt safe in good I always have
with other women and other actresses do
you feel a responsibility to Angelina
just to like show how important it is to
support women especially when you're on
set with them in this business yes yes I
mean I think it it seems it's just to
come so naturally it's not it's not
really a you know I don't really think
about it and then people ask about I
know people ask about era you don't owe
and then you feel this pressure to come
up with some answer when there's nothing
is there so much that's natural
especially the older woman grows them
that maternal that desire to nurture
that especially when you're on cetera
and you're in any situation you you want
to nurture you want to look at men and
women you want to look after your your
colleagues with everywhere the people
are younger onset or whatever it is so
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]